all right now to this story NASA's
solar-powered Mars rover named
opportunity just celebrated its five
thousandth Martian day on the Red Planet
one Martian day is about forty minutes
longer than a day here on earth this is
a huge milestone for the small robot it
was not meant to survive longer than 90
days the rover is collecting data and
photos which are crucial for exploring
Mars colonizing the planet is just one
of the topics in a new book called the
future of humanity terraforming Mars
interstellar travel immortality and our
destiny beyond Earth the book's author
is CBS news science and futurist
contributor Michio Kaku he is also a
visit physics professor at the City
University of New York welcome glad to
be on you say exploration is a
possibility and a necessity we'll get to
the possibility part in the moment but
why is it a necessity well you know our
life on the earth is potentially
endangered by asteroid collisions super
volcano eruptions
not to mention self-inflicted problems
like global warming and nuclear warfare
now we need an insurance policy a
back-up plan
now remember the dinosaurs did not have
a space program that's why they're not
here today hey we do have a space
program and that's why we need a back-up
plan
now no one's saying that we should leave
the earth and go to Mars but a
settlement a settlement on Mars is a
definite possibility and nASA has teamed
up with Silicon Valley billionaires to
make this a reality very hard for the
dinosaurs to do the circuitry with those
talons the tell me about the possibility
you say that you say we're in a golden
age now of space exploration that's
right for 50 years NASA was criticized
as being the agency to nowhere however
now there's a new energy a new
excitement the president has said we're
going to go back to the moon by next
year and then on to Mars and then just
three weeks ago millions of people tuned
into Elon Musk launching of the Falcon
Heavy rocket now that was no ordinary
rocket that was a moon rocket fully
capable of putting astronauts around the
moon funded by private funds well isn't
that the interesting thing because
during the
hollow age the government was very much
into it but now it's very much more in
the private sector that's behind this
that's right Jeff Bezos the richest man
on earth the men behind Amazon has
created his own private spaceport in
Texas he has his own fleet of rockets
Elon Musk wants to create a multi-planet
species in case something happens to us
on the planet Earth and he has set his
sights on to Mars so we're talking about
a new excitement a new energy that we
didn't have for 50 years talk about what
SpaceX is doing tomorrow this demo that
they are launching yeah we're talking
about the fact that the Falcon Heavy
rocket is now in not any ordinary rocket
it has within it the Dragon capsule
which can seat many astronauts and go
fully around the moon now starting next
year we're going back to the moon on an
unmanned mission with the NASA rocket we
have to moon rockets by the way NASA
rocket sponsored by taxpayers and the
Falcon Heavy sponsored by Elon Musk's
SpaceX starting next year we're going to
go back to the moon with an unmanned
mission to surround the moon yeah we can
see your we can always feel your passion
and enthusiasm when you come somebody
said about your books and about you you
always continue to astonish an alarm and
the alarming part must be on page three
when you say one day the earth will end
it will be inhospitable to human life
yeah it's lifting Michio it's sad to say
but 99.9% of all life-forms on the earth
eventually go extinct extinction is the
norm on the planet Earth but we're
different we can reason we can plan we
can plot ahead we don't have to simply
face our doom and remember you for news
that's right and remember we're talking
about events that are so far in the
future no one is saying that global
warming or nuclear warfare is gonna end
humanity anytime soon but we need Plan B
we need a back-up plan just in case and
what do you think about contact with
another alien civilization well let me
stick my neck out I think that in this
century we will have an intercept of a
conversation eavesdropping on aliens and
out of space communicating with each
other we have identified four thousand
planets orbiting
stars we now believe that there could be
over a billion earth-like planets in our
backyard in the galaxy and to assume
that we're the only game in town
I think it's a little bit presumptuous
so I think it's inevitable that yeah we
will make contact with these aliens and
then the question is how come they don't
land on the White House lawn and
advertise their presence yeah what so
there when you guys they'll be shot
right and what are those aliens like
well if you go into the forest do you
talk to the squirrels and the deer maybe
for a while but eventually get bored
because I don't talk back to you michio
when you're in the forest are you
talking to squirrels and deer initially
but I get bored because you don't talk
back to me and if aliens are that
advanced that they land on the earth
we're like squirrels to them we have
nothing to offer to them so they'll
leave us alone for the most part so
mutual is is Mars the place we should be
thinking about I love that you write
about astronauts savoring some of the
aesthetically pleasing rewards of the
Red Planet
it sounds very inviting like the chamber
of commerce but is it is it Mars that we
should be think about or those other
earth-like planets that might be
discovered soon enough well Mars is the
closest game in town Venus of course is
spectacular but it's super hot 900
degrees fahrenheit on the surface of
Venus Mars is cold but it's it's doable
and we have as you know probes already
have looked at the surface of Mars
scoped out potential landing sites and
private entrepreneurs Jeff Bezos Elon
Musk they have set their sights on Mars
because they realize that it's
earth-like and we can even begin the
process of terraforming Mars
now we're terraforming the earth right
now that's called global warming we're
changing the earth we can also change
Mars of course over a period of many
many many decades but we can change Mars
to become more earth-like do you have a
desire to go there I'm a coward when it
comes to space I like that my two feet
on the ground let someone else do the
heroics but a new generation of young
children they're being energized because
they say to themselves I want to be that
asset I want to go to Mars this is a new
Sputnik moment for the next generation I
will cheer them on
squirrels are more of her boast there
yeah girls are very chatty thank you
very much
the future of humanity is the name of
its book it's out today wherever you
like to buy your books you got lots of
choices